ça ira j'espère être bon jour
dépêchez-vous le concours de chanson va
bientôt reprendre
c'est au tour de julie mesdames
mesdemoiselles et messieurs la deuxième
concurrent de notre concours de chanson
sera mademoiselle julie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de tout ça
vous rêvez
qui voit les filles et garçons casimir
chante
françois
une voie facile
mais je me rami ou pas la cgt
les geôles aurait mieux peu si j'étais
un an
non
haha
[Musique]
à
non
[Applaudissements]
ça
dans le kiosque l'écouté
bien
allait leur sourire qui trompe fraiser
grand a
[Musique]
un papillon passer le temps
assis sur un banc
géant à regarder
put in rsa bat
mais j'aimerais mieux pas si je peux
je jouerai mieux peu si j'étais à nantes
à
[Musique]
h
là
[Musique]
bravo julie tu as très bien chanté j'ai
fait une peur terrible c'est très
impressionnant que raison mais ce n'est
pas fini il faut maintenant attendre les
résultats
oui khademi arrive sur scène le public
va voter mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs nous allons procéder à
l'élection du gagnant grâce à vos
applaudissements et à ma machine à
mesurer les applaudissements voilà le
gagnant sera celui qui a ravi les bravos
les plus forts mois casimir je saurai le
feu juge
le premier prix sera un énorme est
délicieux gâteaux à la crème chantilly
c'est formidable
j'adore la clé gentil alors attention
hein pour la chanson de françois
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
bien machines à mesurer les
applaudissements donne 20 sur 20 ans
brave où tu vas gagner certainement pour
le deuxième concurrent
julie applaudissements écoute julie je
crois que tu as gagné
c'est pas possible c'était beaucoup plus
fort pour toi voici donc les résultats
du concours pantois et julie sont
deuxièmes ex-aequo deuxième a dû se
tromper premier est gagnant du concours
casimir pas quelques jours alors il a
même pas chanter désigner un tien tu es
là comment se fait-il que ce soit
gagnant tu ne m'aimes pas chanter c'est
par souci d' injustice à de justice pour
nous voudrions avoir une petite
explication il est normal que ce soit le
premier qui mange le gâteau n'est ce pas
tiendrait on ne peut rien dire ça bon
alors je suis obligé d'être le gagnant
parce que j'ai déjà à manger le gâteau
[Musique]
avec une chanson imagination j'avoue
sans remède dans notre pays ne soyez pas
terrorisé je suis le monde qui pays
je m'appelle casini
[Musique]
sinon si l'on manie maladroit
et moi
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis né smalling amis si j'aime la
glace son choix mais c'est bon droit
c'est mon droit
rafik de chansons
un peu d'imagination
sans meinau dans notre it is the bee du
bonheur tranquille
c'est qu'on peut rencontrer ne soyez pas
terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui périra
appel qu'à
j'ai une malle magique elle une idée
fantastique je mange
lou bulgare est jeune on ma
[Musique]
j'ai vu le nil de cocagne au cinéma méga
c'est mon droit à plus de chansons
imaginez
[Musique]
mais dans notre ici jeu
1h10
ils vous feront compris
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
je m'appelle kazim
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]